yesterday I was checking out Donald
Trump's Twitter account as I often do
and there was plenty of sort of weird
grammar and random capitalization very
very childish language syntax and in the
midst of all that I saw Trump tweeting
pictures of a wall and some construction
equipment saying we're starting the
Mexico wall construction and I found it
sort of weird because they're only now
working on getting some of the initial
money to start some border wall
construction so I thought how could it
be that they're already starting
construction like it can take days just
to even get the equipment to where it
needs to be so today I looked into it in
more detail and it turns out that Trump
actually tweeted pictures of previously
planned repairs to existing areas of
border fencing that have actually been
there since the 1990s and Donald Trump's
pictures are completely misleading
fabrications but I'm sure that they're
playing really really well with his base
Trump tweeted yesterday great briefing
this afternoon on the start of our
southern border wall and if you look at
the pictures a number of them there
you'll see pictures of what genuinely
appears to be construction of some kind
of wall or fence but it turns out that
this project Trump is tweeting about
started almost 10 years ago it has
nothing to do with Trump whatsoever and
in fact some of the exact same pictures
that Trump included in his tweet were
tweeted weeks ago by border patrol in a
post about the replacement of a section
of a couple of miles of fence that was
already predetermined that it would take
place and what's more there hasn't even
been a decision made yet as to what the
new wall will look like as well as if
and when construction will start which
it hasn't yet it's another day and it's
another lie and the theme that we're
seeing is the belligerence of the lies
going on right whole cloth concocted
lies yesterday sarah huckabee sanders on
the census on census questions on the
i'm sorry
citizenship questions on the sense
issue saying of the other than 2010
we've had a question about citizenship
on every census since 1965 whole cloth
fabrications Trump just tweeting
pictures of something that's completely
unrelated to his Mexico border wall and
I think that this is a good opportunity
to take this even further the new
conversation about the wall is how much
money will be made available for it will
the military pay for it right that's a
new idea that Donald Trump has come up
with when will we be able to start
construction on it
this is providing cover for the premise
and promise that's been long forgotten
that Mexico was going to pay for the
wall right Donald Trump throughout the
campaign said Mexico is gonna pay for
the wall that I promised you who's even
talking about that anymore nobody
because it was alive from the beginning
it was never going to happen and it's
the last thing that right-wingers want
to talk about and if you force them to
talk about it they'll say well it's the
fault of Democrats or Mexicans or
whoever that it's not going to happen if
it were up to Trump it would but that's
the whole point a lot of things that if
they were up to the candidate would
happen if it were up to Bernie we'd have
Medicare for all that doesn't mean that
just promising it with no plan is
something we should excuse because if it
were unilaterally up to them it would
happen and I was thinking about this and
I wondered is it possible that someone
maybe to keep Trump from becoming irate
we know he gets it twice a day
propaganda good news file is it possible
someone came to trump with these
pictures and said look mr. Trump they're
building the wall and Trump has been
tricked into thinking that this is the
wall I don't know I saw an interesting
analogy on Reddit a lot of us growing up
if you had Nintendo your little brother
or sister wanted to play and maybe it
wasn't a two-player game or you didn't
want to be bothered so you would hand
them a controller that wasn't plugged
into anything and they would just be
happy because they thought that they
were playing is the equivalent being
done with Trump where he was given
pictures of this border fence and he
genuinely thinks they're doing the thing
he well I don't know I think he was
actively trying to deceive his base you
Jews and that's because he has to
fulfill that campaign promise when it
comes to some of the other ones like the
Econo
he's going to soar or we're gonna win so
much gonna be tired of winning but that
stuff you can kind of like cherry-pick
information when it comes to the wall
when in 2020 comes around it's gotta be
is there a wall constructed on the
southern border or is there not well and
it's very clear what they're going to
say which is they'll use stuff like
what's happening the replacement of
fencing from 1990's that has been
scheduled to be replaced for almost ten
years they'll say that's an example of
Trump achieving it if he's not able to
achieve more lie after lie after lie
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by brilliant
which is a great online service that
allows you to master concepts in math
science and engineering by solving fun
and challenging problems and unlike
other learning sites when I'm using
brilliant I'm learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems you solve challenging puzzles
that have been designed by expert
educators and professionals from all
over the world they don't move too fast
they don't move too slowly they take you
step-by-step through the topics you're
interested in at your own pace and one
of their principles is effective
learning is active watching youtube
videos which is great by the way I
encourage it and I do it all the time
that's a more passive form of learning
that gets you so far
that's when brilliant comes in and
you're watching you're learning not by
watching but by actually doing and you
can get started right now at brilliant
org slash David Pakman first 200 to
visit the website brilliant org slash
David Pakman we'll get 20% off an annual
premium membership but of course sign up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman